hello this is brad gaddis the author of
advanced google adwords
along with simplylearn we're going to
walk you through the fundamentals of
adwords in this first lesson we will
introduce you to google adwords and get
you started on the path of learning how
to use this advertising system
now in every lesson we have certain
objectives or things you want to take
away from watching the video
in this first one we want you to
understand the basics of paid search
advertising
know what a search query is
see how keywords trigger ads to be
displayed
identify the role of an ad in paid
search
ceo adwords can be tracked know how you
pay for adwords and understand the basic
targeting options
so first let's define what is adwords
so first we need to look at search
so when a user conducts a search they're
actually typing in a search query this
is what a user types under the search
bar
and they conduct this query based upon
something they want to learn
and so these search pages are often
called serps or search engine result
pages
now a serp contains both free and paid
listings
so the listings in yellow are paid ads
these are the ads we're going to talk
about throughout these modules
the listings in blue are the free
results these are often called earned or
organic or free based listings
now search results both paid and free
are relevant to the query the query is
what someone types into an engine when
they're trying to learn something
they're trying to get answers about some
piece of information
so the goal then of adwords
and google for their free listings is to
make sure that the results are given to
a user are relevant to what a user is
looking for
now what happens is when your ads
displayed and someone clicks on that ad
that's when you actually pay
[Music]
so you don't pay when your ad is
displayed so a major benefit of adwords
is that you only pay when a potential
customer visits your site
you can send a user to any page on your
website the page they go to from an ad
is known as the landing page
so you only pay when a relevant
interested user actually clicks on your
ad and goes to your site
this is why it's often called pay per
click or cost per click advertising
because with ppc or cpc pay per click or
cost per click you only pay when someone
actually comes to your site
so let's look at some of the
fundamentals of how adwords works
so inside your account your first step
is to choose keywords
so your ad only appears if someone
searches for your keyword
now you can show for some variations
between how your keyword matches to the
search query
but a search query is what someone types
on the engine
a keyword is what you create in your
account
when these two match each other and
we'll talk about match types later on
that's when your ad can be displayed
so once you pick keywords you're going
to write ads for a select group of
keywords
so an ad it's your advertisement that
shows after someone conducts a search
that matches one of your keywords
so you group your keywords and ads
together all your ads in an ad group
which is a collection of keywords and
ads should be related so when someone
searches for something that matches your
keyword the ad is relevant to what the
user searched for
so when a user right conducts a search
query that matches your keyword then
your ad can show
so when you make nice groupings of
related keywords and ads the ads should
be relevant to the search query because
the search is looking for answers so the
ad that matches their intent why they
searched is going to be the ad that they
click
so once someone clicks on an ad
you pay cost per click model you pay for
the click and you receive a visitor to
your website
now you can bid based upon goals you can
set goals through advertising as you
should with any advertising
various website actions you could set
goals based upon visitors to your site
your position of your ads whatever you
really want
then when someone comes to your site and
they do some action you can track this
so this is known as a conversion when
someone completes a specific action on
your site that you want to track
such as completed forms such as lead
generation an e-commerce checkout a
phone call watching a video if something
happens on your site you can track it
and you can label it as a conversion
so in an adwords you can look at what
keywords what ads etc led to actions on
your site
you are paying per click it's not it's
an auction based environment
so you're going to want to change your
bids and your budgets based upon your
goals and those actions that are
happening
so using conversion data lets you make
data driven decisions about how much you
want to bid what keywords you should use
in your account if you're testing ads
see which ad is the best if you want to
add or remove keywords and make
decisions in the account of things we're
going to walk through
you always want to make decisions based
upon good data and so conversion
tracking allows you to see
what actions are happening on your site
and have those statistics in your
account based upon your keywords and
your bids and so forth
so the average process is fairly
straightforward
you choose keywords
you write ads for those keywords
and that's your first ad group
and then when a search query what user
typed in the engine matches your keyword
your ad can be displayed now you're not
charged for a display
when someone clicks on your ad and goes
to your website that you actually pay
for that click and that visitor
then when someone comes to your site and
they do some action you can track those
conversions or those actions that occur
on your website
and use that data to refine your
campaigns
your ads can show in multiple places so
we're going to introduce the basics of
google's various networks
so first we have google search sites
so the search network is comprised of
search engines where ads can be
displayed so the primary network is of
course google and google own site such
as google co uk
google australia google us etc
now the search partner network are
search partners they're still search
engines that are non-google sites
so for instance ask.com is a google
search partner so when you do searches
on ask.com the ads are coming from
adwords in many cases ask does have its
own ad system so not always from adwords
but when your adwords ads can show up on
ask
now beyond search there's something
known as the display network
the display network is made up of
publishers non-search sites
who display ads from adwords in a
non-search based environment
so the new york times or cd kitchen are
publishers they're websites full of
great content
and based upon various targeting options
that we'll talk about later
your ads can show on these non-search
partners this is known as the display
network or google display network
you can also choose targeting options
for your ads
targeting options can contain multiple
options that dictate when and how an ad
can be displayed
so one of the basic targeting options
that you always have to pick
is location and language
the location target depends on where
your ad is going to show
so you could have an ad show in multiple
countries a single country a region a
metro down to a specific city or even
radius around a business
you can choose what language the
searchers are using when your ad is
displayed as well
there's a lot more targeting options
which we'll cover in later modules such
as time of day or day of the week
demographic targeting remarketing which
is when someone came to your website did
something and you want to show ads on
display based upon that behavior so
there's a lot more targeting options the
basics to think about is you can have
your ad shown in any location you want
to define
and you can pick the languages so to
recap our introduction to google adwords
so to recap our introduction to google
adwords
pay per click or ppc is known as
pay-per-click advertising
that's the overall system itself
now a search query is what a user types
into a search engine
a keyword is what goes into your
account now when this search query what
someone typed into an engine matches
your keyword that's when your ad can be
displayed now you're not charged for
your ad being displayed
if the user then finds your ad relevant
and clicks on your ad
they go to your landing page the first
page someone sees after clicking on an
ad the landing page and you then pay
[Music]
so a big benefit of search advertising
is that you're only reaching users
interested in what you're advertising is
you define your keywords and you only
pay when you get a person
to your website
you can use conversion tracking
to view what keywords and ads are
leading to actions so a conversion is
any action you wanted to find on your
website
you can choose where your ads are
displayed in location targeting
you can choose a lot of other targeting
options such as the language of the
searcher as well
so this concludes our introduction
adwords in our next lesson we'll look at
the adwords account structure in more
depth
thank you
you